when we think of anime today is hard to
ignore one aspect that has seemingly
taken over the medium as we know it in
the modern day mo way
[Music]
mowie anime mo way girls mo way shows
whether it be a star or genre or just a
feeling is hard to explain exactly what
mo way is to an uninformed outsider yet
anyone familiar with anime will grow to
have an unspoken understanding of it
because it is everywhere nowadays no
absolutely dominates anime but it wasn't
always like this
in fact it's something that many of you
may have witnessed the rise of yourself
within the very life span of your anime
fandom how did such a vague broad
concept rise to prominence to become
synonymous with the modern anime culture
how long has Maui been around for anyway
and how is it evolved over the years
today I wanted to tell the story of my
way how his journey led to it taking
over the medium as we see it today and
maybe unravel the secret formula behind
what seems to be just cute anime girls
this is the mo a revolution to
understand where mo a came from we first
need to understand what mo a actually is
and that's easier said than done
aside from it having something to do
with making your kokoro go doki doki
literature club it's been very commonly
debated as to how Maui is truly defined
now I don't think we just can be able to
grab an Oxford English Dictionary off
the shelf and find a hard definition of
what mo a is so maybe we can use the
next best thing
urban dictionary mo e is when your heart
gets a boner huh that's that's that's
actually pretty accurate
wait sir if you're female does that mean
Maori characters make your heart go more
exercise the idea that Maui is when your
heart gets the bonus pretty much the one
sentence definition I normally settle on
when describing it to strangers but I
think it's cause a feeling of affection
or attraction towards a specific
character or character traits that comes
from a place of innocence some may
describe it as a burning desire to
protect a character some may describe it
as character features that evoke a deep
endearment some may describe it as just
cute it's very subjective for the most
part as if you're really inclined
anything can be moe a even guts or
Donald Trump could be mo aid even mo
could be mo a mo a Szyslak the exact
definition is not so much as important
to see how anime characters have evolved
over the years to more effectively
capture this emotion and attachment to a
mass audience
and with that in mind how far do the
roots of mow a traced back to for such a
vague concept it's hard to point to a
specific origin point as it could be
argued that the idea of constructing
characters with the goal of eliciting an
intimate responsive affection is as old
as the medium itself however I think a
good place to start is looking for early
character traits and tropes which would
eventually evolve into what we know as
modern waifu culture as it is the
audience attachment to these trace that
would be refined and grow into the mo
way we know today many have cited Lum
from the 1978 manga others say yotsuba
has been the progenitor of Maui as we
know it and possibly the very first
waifu a very cute and innocent character
at first glance but one with a fiery
temper who refers to the main
protagonist as darling hmm she's often
credited as being the first cinder ray
so it comes as no surprise that she's
such an important an iconic character in
the medium but of course at the time
this was just a new character trait
audiences responded well too and she
certainly wasn't created for the purpose
of being a waifu this would also be seen
in characters like Lynn Minmei from the
original stf Matt cross and earring team
any trace we've seen popular female
characters nowadays as well as being one
of the earliest idol characters that
just happens to be in a mecha show and
at the time with far more focus on the
mecha side of things in terms of the
whole design and aesthetics we can see a
lot of influence from bishoujo designs
which have had its own devolution
throughout the history of anime but of
course for the show that would really
popularize the aspects we would come to
know in modern Maui it would be hard to
argue against bishoujo Senshi Sailor
Moon considering how much of an
international success this show was
think about how much it has in common
with modern Maui shows today a full cast
of varied female characters in an
entirely feminine art style that
actually had a large male audience the
show Joe shows of the 80s and 90s with a
significant male audience was a major
turning point in the development of the
mo a concept these characters weren't
there as fanservice eye candy or love
interest for the male protagonists they
were the main focus of the show and that
is how dedicated Maui shows operate now
health for Sailor Moon specifically some
have even theorized the origin of the
word mo a itself came from Sailor Saturn
Hotaru Tomoya there are many other
characters like these that either
display modern Maui trace or simply
captured male audiences over the years
but the last hugely important thing I
want to mention
influences extended beyond just Maui is
of course neon genesis evangelion yes
once again I am mentioning Evangelion
for the [ __ ] I don't know just assume
next time I'm talking about the
evolution of an aspect within anime
Evangelion is gonna have some part in it
and in this case let's just say Oscar
and Rey are a big deal as far as Marie
is concerned they really changed the
game as far as how audiences reacted to
female characters audiences were deeply
attached and loyal as well this was
arguably the first proper waifu war just
think about how many characters we've
seen over the years that have been
influenced by them it was at this point
in the 90s that the character archetypes
we know today were firmly solidified and
more importantly what Evangelion proved
was the franchising power of it
everything was franchised in Ava
including its wife who's still to this
day and it is this financial success
that is important to note because in all
these shows whilst many of them had
great stories it was the audience
connection to the characters that made
them as big as they were this simple
idea of an intimate personal attachment
towards a character would play a massive
role in the evolution of the concept
because this meant fan base investment
the more a fan cares about a show or
even a single specific aspect or
character of that show the more likely
they are to invest into the franchise as
a whole it's turned the characters
themselves into a marketable brands and
companies would slowly realize how
profitable this was in all genres
branding plays a huge role in the
success of a given show and by
capitalizing on the emotional response
these shows were able to thrive be it
through merchandising home video sales
or whatever else as time progressed to
the early 2000s we would continue seeing
trace of my way across the board in
shows like
azumanga daioh but it was a small part
of a larger whole mowie certainly was
present throughout anime but it wasn't
as recognized or as prevalent in the
culture it was simply one aspect you'd
find in anime you could point to the odd
character having cute in quirky aspects
we had our established character
archetypes but no one yet had come along
to fully take advantage of the
franchising potential MOA could give to
a property this was all about to change
however with one studio that would
explode onto the scene downright
perfecting the modern formula leading to
a change felt across the medium that we
still see today the revolution was about
to begin
[Music]
whilst the true origins of mao-a are
widely debatable I'm sure we can all
agree that was the show's created by
Kyoto Animation in the mid to late 2000s
that cemented the concept in the
mainstream anime consensus before the
full-on mo a powerhouse Kyoto Animation
is known for today you may remember
though it wasn't always this way
well started as a small animation studio
based in Kyoto wait wait can someone
fact check that for me please
they would get their first big break in
making a spin-off to a mecha series Full
Metal Panic for mo foo and then its
eventual sequel in the second range and
in 2005 would also release air it's this
period where we started to see the rise
of shows with the more recognized more
modern mo a style that we have now and
this would lay the groundwork for their
next show which would truly solidify the
oncoming revolution
[Music]
change was coming and it was in the form
of a bossy brunettes high school girl
who was a god literally the melancholy
of haruhi suzumiya blasted onto screens
in 2006 and hera he stamped down her
presence which was felt across the whole
community and he went around just over
ten years ago well remember how much of
a cultural phenomenon this was for our
community because the whole quirkiness
of the show was something that we hadn't
really seen before before anime was
known for its futuristic cyberpunk giant
robots shown in fights and then
seemingly overnight everyone was doing a
synchronized dance to a hyperactive J
pop song starting religions around a
high school girl and scouting people for
the SOS Brigade
it wasn't just about Hera he was about
to buying into her ethos Hera he wasn't
just another anime girl Hera he was a
God and she was your God one whom you
must obey we had high school girl hair
icky bunny girl hair icky bunny go Hera
key with a guitar a catchy dance only
dedicated fans would be able to pull off
Anaya harana who was catapulted into
superstar status everything about this
show was franchised marketed and sold
the show created his own culture and
people bought into it people bought into
it in spades the success of the show
skyrocketed MO into the forefront of the
anime consensus I mean I know this was
my first show where I learned what my
way was in this situation mola is an
important concept to keep in mind sorry
what'd you say mo a was in my way was
profitable and Hara he became a symbol
of the fan base investment into this
quirky anime girl culture and I think
this was due to a partially being
self-aware and partially celebrating
everything it was being self-aware about
but Kyoto Animation didn't stop there
they continued their history of adapting
key shows with the Canon or you make in
late 2006 and of course clannad's both
of which have a great deal of mao-a
elements in their own rights but it
would be the release of lucky star that
fully encapsulated everything we now
expect of mao-a shows lucky stars all
levels of popularity equal or even
exceeding that of Hera heat a show but a
group of schoolgirls really just being
cute and hanging out something which a
young 18 year old Giga at the time did
not get in his second ever video on
YouTube I still kind of don't really get
it well this show did was take one of
the elements fans liked about Hera he
the cute girls relatable main character
the high school setting and amped up the
mo aspect
it proved that you didn't need a sci-fi
twist to engage an audience audiences
could find a connection even if there
wasn't a big overarching plot and with
it the momentum Kyoto Animation gained
from releasing these shows back-to-back
was enormous they had set the stage Maui
was growing rapidly and they were right
at the forefront of it everything they
touched seemed to turn into gold what
they didn't know was what they touched
next would turn into pure diamond
when we think of influential shows in
the history of anime we think of
international mega hits like Akira
Evangelion and Dragon Ball Z anime that
had an industry-wide effect and
influenced their genres for years to
come so seven years after some no-name
on the internet reviewed Kay on and
publicly exclaimed that this was a
nothing show about cute girls drinking
[ __ ] tea I can now regarding
Lee admit that Kay on is one of the most
important and influential shows to come
out for modern anime that just came out
of my mouth
[ __ ] T Kalin was the final
evolution character animation has set in
a path they started while Harry he could
still be seen as a high school comedy
with a sci-fi twist and lucky star could
be seen as a slice-of-life high school
comedy in the same vein as azumanga
daioh just with a very very strong Maui
element K on wasn't really any of those
it was just Maui and it was the first
time people started calling an entire
show as such this was something the
community hadn't seen before the main
selling point wasn't its ground plot
points it wasn't its gut-busting comedy
romance or action it was just the fluffy
feeling of being able to hang with cute
cuddly anime girls sure it had its music
but that was never the main focus much
to the dismay of many who didn't
understand the show but the focus was on
the chemistry shared between its
characters characters that individually
may not seem like anything special but
for vast audiences the whole wood turned
out to be much greater than the sum of
its parts I'm probably not the best
person to be able to tell you about what
the appeal of k-on was but what I
certainly can tell you about is it
success audiences felt a deep connection
to these girls and it was primarily a
male demographic - from their designs to
the girls personalities to the various
scenarios they'd find themselves in to
the chemistry that they all shared Kay
on had perfected the Maui formulas so
much it found his success by just
reveling in its own mo Ennis
[Music]
this would go on to become one of the
highest selling blu-ray releases for his
time ke on made mo a the biggest thing
in anime after its release
it wasn't Mecca it wasn't action all
romance it was cute girls doing cute
things and it changed the way we look at
anime today K on wasn't just popular K
on didn't just cement Maui or start some
kind of trend K on damn-near created its
own genre the evolution became a
revolution
what came next was a plethora of shows I
can only describe as belonging in the
Maui Shan rrah now a lot of people
myself included have referred to Maui as
a genre before so let's just set the
record straight and say definitively
Maui isn't a genre technically in the
same way that Shonen isn't technically a
genre but people often refer to it as
one because of the trends and
commonalities we find within the shows
in this case Maui describes the general
theme and tone of the show and his
characters for the most part I show
someone would drop in this mo a genre
would likely just be a slice of life
drama or comedy but with how broad that
definition is it doesn't really tell you
what you need to know planet s and great
teacher onizuka can also be described in
that way but they sure as hell aren't mo
a show's K on and lucky star may not
have been the first examples of cute
girls doing cute things but they sure as
hell cemented the concept into the
mainstream and more importantly directed
my way down and more defines path
because it was sure has held these show
successes that others try to emulate it
was this new subset of slice of life
series that would essentially purpose
towards appealing to this cute mo a
feeling as we discussed before Maui is a
very broad term that is subjective for
every individual but what Kyoto
Animation did was perfect of working
formula it made mo a more targeted more
marketable it was a tangible thing that
other companies could try to replicate
he had the more rounded cuter art style
a bunch of character archetypes and
almost all female cast little to no roam
out scenarios you could put them in and
a fresh new audience and I found out
this was a thing they wanted and would
invest deeply in you could even say this
started a Maui arms race and one genre
to benefit the most from this time
period was of course idol shows now Idol
shows actually go back a pretty long way
in anime but I don't think it's any
surprise that the surge in popular idol
shows came in at time of the mowie boom
that k-on started as you can see how a
successful formula have influenced the
idol genre I mean what are the kind of
shows would be able to thrive in an
environment where the audience wanted a
core of pure innocent character
archetypes being brought together where
we as an audience member can watch them
bond and grow together Idol master love
life these now mega popular franchises
rose up in a post que on era following
the groundwork that it had lay was it
cute yes was it marketable [ __ ] yes was
their deep fanbase investment
are you [ __ ] kidding me
I don't shows it still going strong and
I firmly establish themselves in their
own genre but while Maui has definitely
had a strong influence there it also
blew up in other places but not
everything has shared this same
longevity during the height of the Maui
boom everyone wants to find the next
cute girls doing cute things mega hit
and while Kay on had a deeper soul
behind it the audience's latched on to
the same cannot be said for others that
tried jumping on this bandwagon the term
Maui blob was coined on the simple
criticisms of characters in these
vanilla shows feeling Sammy and
pandering a Maya blob is just there as a
character that's meant to be my way for
the audience and sometimes ends up
feeling way too obvious and completely
falls flat the core concept of shows
trying to pander to Maori troupes
exclusively quickly annoyed audiences
because they were more than sick of
seeing it so now much like with Idol
shows the industry had to find creative
and unique ways to make these shows feel
fresh and interesting you can't just
have cute girls doing cute things
anymore you see you've got to have cute
girls doing other things so long as
they're doing it cutely so now we've got
fine examples like cute girls doing
airsoft cute girls doing game design
cute girls doing motorbike racing cute
girls doing tank curry that's that's not
[ __ ] word you idiot cute girls doing
amazing things that we'll never be able
to achieve in our lifetime because we're
stuck here watching some video
documenting the history of cue anime
girls but that's just natural evolution
Maui had to take purely Maui blob shows
are becoming a less common thing in this
day and age but in its place you have
these shows taking Maori elements but
adding an extra hook to appeal to
audiences with specific interests and
that brings us to the latest form of
Maui shows in modern anime let's say you
wanted to make a Maui show with a hook
for people who are interested in ships
well what if we make the girls pilot the
ships no the girls are the ships
anthropomorphism is the current big
trend besides idols in Maui anime the
immense success of the can tie
collection mobile game could be easily
seen as partly responsible for this
so whether they're boats guns horses or
[ __ ] household appliances these are
the levels Maui shows need to go to
these days for
people to pay attention to them but
here's the thing even though we can
point to the evolution of moe a show
specifically an idols slice of life or
alpha morphism the effects of it can be
seen in the much wider anime landscape
in recent years we've become so
accustomed to seeing it that it's just
become a normal part of anime now and to
me that is the final evolution of what
moe a has become in this modern era
a versus K on and his predecessors in
some way or another Maui has crept into
the modern anime landscape in a way
unlike any other trends that came before
it in the mecha video we talked about
how his evolution directly influenced
decades of a genre and eventually died
down noe
hasn't done that Maui hasn't separated
itself into an exclusive Mirwais genre
it's done quite the opposite
instead it has spread throughout the
entire medium as we know it and become
synonymous with anime itself and what I
find so interesting is that this change
in landscape happened within my lifespan
of my anime fandom it's not something I
read about or her people talk about in
the past
I saw it happen a lot of us saw it
happen Maui feels like it's always been
there sure there was a time when we
became more aware of it and many believe
there is a trend that's come and gone
but it hasn't gone anywhere
it's just slipped between the cracks and
taken over a huge part of the identity
of what anime is today the influence of
Maui is in almost every genre of modern
anime anime characters have learned how
to be much more direct in targeting that
specific mo a feeling even if the
characters themselves aren't designed to
be Maui
everyone has a cute quirk every girl
needs a unique selling point even if
it's just something completely
surface-level
we're in a time when female characters
that trend aren't necessarily the
deepest or most fleshed out they're the
ones with the most unique gimmick the
ones whose designs more stand out for
you see because the concept of mo a can
be applied to any show it now almost
does apply to every show whether
directly an obvious or simply then the
background of some characters who act in
a way we just expect characters to act
now Maui is the norm even if you're not
specifically a fan of mo a shows some of
you may think I'm overdramatizing the
impact of these cute anime girls but the
thing is these aren't just cute anime
girls they're brands they're marketable
products that can be commoditized and
sold and we proudly buy into it it's a
million dollar franchise is a
fashionable art style something for us
to argue over who is cuter who is better
who is
best they have become as much of a
symbol for our medium as giant robots
and muscly action heroes were in the
past
and continue to be an integral part of
the culture that we love that's what I
mean when I say was a revolution because
it was a successful one moy may have
always existed in one form or another
but now it is at the forefront stamping
down his mark on the medium without
going anywhere anytime soon it was a mo
a uprising it was a mo a takeover it was
a mo a revolution
[Applause]
[Music]
so quick announcement felt good going
through my old videos in the process of
making this my video and just seeing my
older shitty videos and we got the idea
to make a [ __ ] team ugh based
on my original K on video for the three
people that actually remember it see if
you want to grab this what I think is
probably like my first og me my ever
made back like seven years ago then I'll
put a link in the description it's gonna
be a limited time thing cuz I don't
think many people are gonna remember it
it'll be up for like two weeks till the
fourth of August so get one more you can
because I'm not gonna leave Memphis and
you don't even need to drink tea out of
it I'm drinking coffee right now just
don't tell anyone but with that said
thank you very much to Robert I'm bork
basil Patrick Manson Vincent Mooney now
Ken and everyone else a patron for
helping to support me for this month and
making this video possible
is videos like these that require the
most time research and resources so I
would not be able to do bigger projects
like these without your support on there
especially if these don't do as well but
I always love working on them not sure
what my next big genre breakdown is
gonna be just yet but I'm gonna be
excited to work on it anyway that's it
for me if you want the limited time mug
go click a link in the description but
otherwise I've been gig ugh and I will
see you all next time